[Music]
all right y'all welcome back we've got
Joel with those hanging out our next
guest is one of the greatest
percussionists of all time but you
already know that because you heard her
play with my band on the Koke earlier
and you just know her career she's
incredible her new salsa album is coming
out next year and the single that I am
not going to mess up is called bimba
Colora I think drops in January I'm
gonna ask her to correct me if I'm wrong
go um so everybody give it up for Sheila
E
[Music]
[Applause]
B it sounds sexy when you say it
okay but I didn't know this but you were
on the Renaissance album Beyonce's album
is as well is it is it CET is that the
one yeah did you not know it either till
like I did not this is amazing so
because you like you text me play on
this song and you never know when
something's going to come out or not and
I played uh recorded with Rafael sadik
because he grew up with us so we're from
the Bay Area from Oakland and so we're
always in the studio so we're just
recording stuff and next thing you know
Beyonce's team comes to the studio and
they like that song and so I'm in the
park walking my dog and so says congrat
they start texting me congratulations
you're on the new Beyonce song I said no
I'm not cuz I didn't I wasn't in a
studio with you're thinking of somebody
else yeah you're like yeah and I I had
no idea so I I'm walking my dog more
text than I called Raphael I was like
they're telling me that I'm on the the
song and and you produced it I don't
remember being in the studio with you on
that song they said no that's you they
ended up taking the the portion that we
did and then adding on top of it I was
like oh okay well did I get did I get
paid
yes yes that was the next question
that's my firm question that was it yeah
no that's incredible though so they took
what you did and then created a song out
of that that's even more of a compliment
no it it was Rafael he wrote the song
and I played on top of that song and
then they took that point but yeah so
I'm want that's how I get on things I
never know but you got your Walk of Fame
star recently yeah this is five summer
that was incredible yeah congratulations
that's so cool a thank you and and yeah
this is so cool is that where when did
when did you first meet Ringo when did
y'all first meet up o uh I want to say
2001 or 2003 I can't remember but I got
the call for me but definitely not 2002
no no I know it wasn't it was one it was
an odd number I man you are so being in
New York yes but like definitely not the
two yeah yeah not the two okay it was
odd okay it was an odd number odd yeah
were you excited exed like to meet up
and like hey did you all playing or I
have a crazy bucket list that was not on
my list for me to meet Ringle star let
alone play with him like both of us
playing drums together in his band that
I was tripping out and I was the first
ever and still the only woman playing in
that band in all of his uh Allstar bands
so he put the yeah allar allar and he's
still doing it I'm the only beet thing
oh that is did she get a star for that I
was like name so you're I find this
incredible I you told me this before but
you've never made a salsa album this is
your first like salsa album which I find
incredibly odd I know it's weird I I
mean I my dad the legendary pet es Cavo
he my dad
guessed Latin jazz that's what I grew up
that's the foundation of who I am and
being in the bay all the different just
you're a percussionist and you're so
well known I just assume no but Sala
music is totally different it's very
strict like it's something that I mean I
I think this is the best record I've
ever done in my life what a beautiful
thing I'm like touched by like I I have
Ruben blades singing he's amazing I mean
if people know yeah thank you Ruben
blades I I cried when I heard the first
verse because it's something that I it's
like if I do a soft record he's got to
be the first one HTO santosa Sayang
Gloria Stefon I love her Debbie Noah
yeah we have so many um yeah there's so
many amazing people singing and
performing on on this record it took me
almost two years to do it it's inspiring
though in the sense of like me you
already have this massive a career you
know both of you like you don't need to
do anything at this point but then you
do something because you just have a
desire to do it and then it's like some
it's one of your most proud projects
that's incredible incredible no it
really is I'm so proud and and it's
crazy because taking that long to do
something I was going to try to put it
out this year and it's like no this is
not the right time we have to wait just
take out because I have another album
out that's already out now girl I know
you're always working I know every time
like I text I'm like she is going to
Germany I kept apparently I was like all
right well everybody we need another
break look out for Sheila's salsa album
coming next year and the single bimba
which drops in January I tried to say it
sexy for you we've got Ashley flowers
from the hit podcast crime junkie here
next we'll be right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home